There was a study where they had a bunch of rats in a cage and they left the gate open.
And every time the rats would try to leave, they'd get shocked.
They'd try to leave, they'd get shocked.
Eventually the rats would stop trying to leave.
Fast forward, those rats had little baby rats.
They put the baby rats in a separate cage and left the gate open.
And they'd never tried to leave.
They'd never been shocked.
They'd never experience that same trauma yet they still acted in that same way.
And that's how we understand epigenetics.
Trauma and response patterns can be passed down to us.
This isn't just through generations, it could be through lifetimes, also something
that may have happened in our childhood.
What situations in our lives are we keeping ourselves in when the gate is wide open?
If it is your birthright to live the most expansive, joy, fault, love, and engaging life
ever, where are you staying stuck where the gate is wide open?
And where do we find and expand our perception to the possibilities that are outside this